speaking of instilling fear
black lives matter is threatening to
burn down the country again
if they don't get the outcome they want
in the trial of derek chovin the cop who
was involved in the death of george
floyd
there is a woman i've never heard of her
but apparently she's popular on social
media
maya eckles she's a model and a black
lives matter
activist and she just took to tik tok
and threatened to burn some stuff down
if they don't get the outcome they want
in the trial
if george floyd's murderer is not
sentenced
just know that all hell is gonna break
loose
don't be surprised when buildings on
fire
that woman is a terrorist right
i'm not using hyperbolic language here
terrorism is
the targeting of civilians to achieve
political purposes so i guess she didn't
specify which buildings would be on fire
but if if you can infer from the way
that blm torched the country last summer
if you can infer from that and deduce
that there would be private buildings
private businesses on fire as well as
government buildings
then what she is doing is
making a criminal threat to burn
places down if we do not subvert our
justice system
to give her what she wants why are we
tolerating
what is the the most basic definition of
terrorism
why why are people going along with this
why is mitt romney
marching with blm terrorists
why is he doing that why are these rep
i never want to hear another word
about the capitol hill riot so long
as people like this lady can get away
with making criminal threats
and in the case of blm and antifa
actually carrying out the threats
as they did for six months in the united
states i don't want to hear a peep about
it
about the trumpist insurrectionists i
just
i just don't want to hear it because
it's so disingenuous it is
in such bad faith and it's not just some
lady mouthing off on tick tock i mean
she identifies herself with the
organization right she identifies
herself with the blm movement
but it's not just her it's not just some
mouthy millennial
making idle threats this sort of thing
is supported
by the most powerful people in the
democrat
liberal establishment how many
democrat politicians voiced their
support for blm last summer as they
burned down the country
kamala harris the sitting vice president
raised money
to bail these people out of jail she
wasn't bailing the peaceful protesters
out of jail the peaceful protesters
weren't
in jail the arsonists and the criminals
were in jail
and she raised money to bail them out
and then she went on national television
and said this shouldn't stop this should
keep going
joe biden's staff members raised money
for these criminals
and yet we are supposed to clutch our
pearls
over donald trump's tweets or something
give me a break
if you enjoyed that video be sure to hit
the subscribe button so everyone waiting
through the wasteland of youtube
knows that we've got the absolute top
content
out there
[Music]
you